you're already likely familiar with the
notion that a dollar in the US a US
dollar is not necessarily equivalent to
one currency unit in another country say
one euro and so if you were traveling to
that country and you are holding dollars
and you need to exchange those dollars
into euros you'd say well how many euros
am I going to get for my dollars or if
you were European and you had a certain
number of euro and you said how many
dollars am I going to get for my euros
you would be thinking about the exchange
rate and it's not just about if you're a
tourist or you're travelling it's also
very important if you're an importer and
exporter if you make say cars in the
United States where all of your costs
are in dollars but you're selling them
in Europe where you're getting your
money in terms of euros and then you
have to convert them back to dollars to
pay your costs well the idea of an
exchange rate matters a lot and so first
let's make tangible what an exchange
rate even looks like and there's many
different ways of representing it the
first thing to appreciate if someone
says what's the exchange rate for the US
dollar your next reaction should be with
regards to what other currency so if I
said what's the exchange rate of the US
dollar with respect to the euro you
could express that as one US dollar
u.s dollar is equal to how many euros
and at the time of this video it's
actually 0.87 euros now another way to
express this is 1 euro 1 euro is equal
to how many US US Dollars and if you
know this first equation you can figure
out the second one you would essentially
just divide both sides by 0.87 if you
divide this by 0.87 you get 1 if you
divide one by 0.87 you're going to get
approximately 1.15 and so at the time of
this video 1.15 u.s. dollars is equal to
one euro or another way to think about
it is if you took a dollar fifteen cents
in the US and convert it to euros you
would get one euro and there's other
ways of expressing it you could say what
is the price of a US dollar
so price of the US dollar in terms of
Euro in terms of Euro so this is how
much would it cost to buy one US dollar
in terms of euros well you could just
look at this over here and you could say
well one US dollar is going to cut cost
0.87 euros or you could say 0.87 euros
euros per US per US dollar and if you
were to go the other way around if you
wanted the price of the Euro price of
the Euro in terms terms of the US dollar
US dollar well that would be the other
way around one euro would cost a dollar
fifteen cents so this would be one point
one five US dollars dollars per euro now
with all of this out of the way let's
actually do some calculations let's
imagine that in the United States a
yellow box goes for twenty dollars these
yellow boxes are in high demand someone
from Europe wants to buy one of these
yellow boxes and they need to buy it for
twenty US dollars but they only have
euro
how many euro would they need in order
to buy that box for twenty US dollars
well if one US dollar is equal to 0.87
euros then twenty US dollars is going to
be 20 times as many euros so we could
say 20 dollars times 0.87 euro per
dollar this symbol right over here is
shorthand for euro and so you are going
to get let's see that would be seventeen
approximately approximately seventeen
point four zero euro and if it went the
other way around let's say that red
boxes are available for purchase only in
Europe for 20 euro an American tourist
goes there
wants to figure out how many US dollars
would they have to convert in order to
be able to pay for one of these red
boxes that are 20 euro well here we see
one euro is equal to one point one five
US dollars so here you would say 20 euro
times one point one five US dollars
dollar per euro and so what is this
going to be this is going to be 20 times
1.15 which is going to be 23 US dollars
23 US dollars now another idea a related
idea to this is this notion that
currencies can appreciate and depreciate
so let's say that the euro appreciates
appreciates and it always matters
relative to something so they say
relative to the dollar so the euro
appreciates relative to the dollar come
up with an exchange rate that would show
the euro appreciating relative to the
dollar with this as a starting point so
one scenario where this is happening is
if this was where you are starting one
euro would now be more US dollars more
than one point one five US dollars so
you have one euro would now be equal to
maybe it's equal to a dollar 20 now so
it's now equal to one dollar 20 cents
now if someone said the dollar
appreciates relative to the euro then it
would go the other way around that might
be one US dollars is now equivalent to
0.9 euros or maybe one euro or 1.05
euros and similarly if someone says that
the euro depreciates depreciates
relative relative to the dollar that's
another way of saying that the dollar
has appreciated relative to the euro so
this could be a situation where if the
euros depreciating relatives the dollar
from this place right over here 1 euro 1
euro is now equal to fewer dollars so
maybe this is now equal to a dollar 5
and with this as a starting point this
would also be a situation where the
dollar has appreciated relative to the
euro so I'll leave you there this is a
primer on exchange rates it can get a
little bit confusing
because you're talking for the price of
a currency in terms of another currency
but I encourage you to keep thinking
about things keep doing these little
thought experiments in your head and
thinking about ok if a euro is equal to
more than a dollar if something's worth
a certain number of euros it should be
larger it should be a larger number in
terms of dollars similarly if a dollar
is less than one euro if something costs
a certain number of dollars it should be
a smaller number in terms of euros